carlos y tamara viven a la misma
distancia de su trabajo y comenzaron a
caminar hacia allá al mismo tiempo ambos
caminaron con una velocidad constante
aunque no necesariamente igual la
distancia y carlos al trabajo en
diversos momentos se muestra en la tabla
a continuación aquí tengo el tiempo aquí
tengo en 50 segundos después de que
empezó a caminar 100 segundos 150
segundos y aquí tenemos la distancia de
carlos a su trabajo medida en metros a
los 50 segundos de haber empezado a
caminar hasta 830 metros a los 100
segundos hasta 760 y a los 150 segundos
estaba a 690 metros cuáles de los
siguientes enunciados pueden ser
verdaderos selecciona todos los que
apliquen me dan todos estos denuncias de
aquí vamos a ver de qué tratan tamara
vive a 830 metros de su trabajo y caminó
hacia él a dos metros por segundo tamara
vive a 900 metros de su trabajo y caminó
hacia él a siete quintos de metro por
segundo
tamara vive a 900 metros de su trabajo y
caminó hacia él las cinco séptimos de
metro por segundo y así son todas las
opciones todas
hablar de la distancia a la que tamara
vive del trabajo y a la velocidad con la
que camina al trabajo
bueno pues veamos que sabemos sabemos
que carlos y tamara viven a la misma
distancia de su trabajo viven a la misma
distancia de su trabajo y comenzaron a
caminar hace ya al mismo tiempo o sea
que si puedo encontrar la distancia a la
que carlos vive de su trabajo puedo
averiguar la distancia a la que tamara
vive su trabajo lo que quiero hacer es
calcular cuál es la distancia de carlos
a su trabajo cuando el tiempo te está en
cero segundos para ello vamos a calcular
la velocidad supongamos que medimos este
intervalo pasamos de 50 a 100 segundos
es decir aumentamos en 50 segundos
nuestro aumento es de 50 segundos
entonces esto corresponde un cambio de
qué distancia pues pasó a estar a 830
metros a 760 metros de su trabajo lo
cual tiene sentido carlos está caminando
hacia el trabajo pero bueno de 830 a 760
significa que hay un cambio d
menos 70 metros por lo tanto la
velocidad con la que carlos está
caminando a su trabajo es de 70 metros
cada 50 segundos y lo podemos verificar
veamos aquí otra vez pasaron 50 segundos
han pasado 50 segundos y acá de nuevo se
corresponde con una disminución de 70
metros en la distancia por lo tanto a
qué distancia vive carlos de su trabajo
pues como camina por velocidad constante
50 segundos antes de estos 50 segundos
tendría que estar 70 metros más lejos
por lo tanto a los 0 segundos carlos
estaba a 900 metros de su trabajo y
noten que es consistente si empiezo en
cero pasan 50 segundos y estoy a 830
metros del trabajo tal como tenía antes
por lo tanto tamara también debe vivir a
900 metros de su trabajo y eso me
permite descartar esta opción porque
tamara no vive a 830 metros tampoco vive
a 760 y tampoco vive de nuevo a 830
pero qué hay de esta cámara bibi a 900
metros de su trabajo y camino hacia él a
siete quintos de metro por segundo pues
esto es perfectamente posible no tengo
nada información acerca de la velocidad
de tamara porque me dicen que no
necesariamente es igual a la de carlos
pero no puedo descartar esta posibilidad
esto es enteramente posible tamara vive
a 900 metros de su trabajo y camino
hacia él a 5 séptimos de metro por
segundo de nuevo no puede descartar esta
posibilidad no tengo información de la
velocidad pero solo importa esto es
enteramente posible así que estas dos
son las opciones correctas